das wird heute 28 weltrekord ii hofft
dass alles funktioniert trainiert hobby
fleißig und ja es ist eine neue
herausforderung die hercules c-130 zu
ziehen
durch meine vergangenheit durch das
militär ist natürlich das was gewaltiges
wollen ihr seid und wir haben 89 des
jagdkommandos machen wiener neustadt das
hat eine ein jahr gedauert und das war
für mich ist die härteste ausbildung was
was überhaupt gibt auf der ganzen welt
ist sein die marines hat nichts gegen
uns lockt man das ein wirkliches ein
wirklich die härtesten unter dieser
sonne
[Applaus]
eine erste ausgabe 23 cm 5 zentimeter
und zehn zentimetern vierten wir 20 cm
und jetzt 20 18 15
es ist extrem schwierig wir haben das
gelernt beim human oder smart das dass
wir keine aufgeber seien und dass man
nie aufgeben